il faut que tout le monde fasse des
efforts je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
réforme injuste des retraites et je le
dis à françois hollande y aura pas de
réforme injuste des retraites si on ne
fait pas un effort pour aligner oui pour
aligner les régimes le privé le public
les régimes spéciaux les parlementaires
aussi pourquoi pas le sujet en réalité
c'est qu'on l'a déjà fait la droite
souvenez-vous a fait cotiser les
fonctionnaires de 37 ans et demi à 40
ans on a commencé à aligner les régimes
spéciaux il faut continuer dans ce sens
et marisol touraine a en réalité
enterrer une réforme juste en disant
qu'elle ne toucherait pas aux régimes de
retraite du secteur public nous sommes
en direct avec valérie pécresse gilles
leclair caisse sur cette réforme puisque
aujourd'hui démarre la confiance sociale
quelle réforme des retraites du
gouvernement vous pourriez voter au fond
vous attendez quoi parce que la cc c'est
une réforme importante pour l'ensemble
des français des citoyens et pour le
pays est ce qu'on pourrait sur cette
question-là surmonter un peu les
clivages politiques qu'est ce que vous
pourriez voter d'abord
je veux dire à françois hollande
puisqu'il ouvre la conférence des
retraites je veux dire à françois
hollande que maintenant l'heure est aux
décisions et à l'action il faut assumer
la réforme est pas essayer de toujours
être dans l'esquivé et dans le
louvoiement qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
selon nous qu'est la réforme que nous
pourrions voter selon moi il faut pas
toucher au pouvoir d'achat des retraites
pourquoi parce que c'est un pacte de
confiance qu'on a conclu avec les
retraités il ne faut pas toucher non
plus aux cotisations des actifs et des
entreprises parce que les actifs ils
vivent moins bien que leurs parents et
les entreprises si on leur augmentent
leurs cotisations sociales elles ne
créeront pas d'emplois or le chômage
aujourd'hui c'est le fléau delà de la
france donc ni baisse des retraites ni
hausse des cotisations ce qu'il faut
c'est allonger la durée de cotisation
est pour moi la bonne solution c'est de
retarder le départ l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite jusqu'à 65 ans à horizon
qui pour convenir aux enfants